good evening and welcome to tucker carl
since i had a ton going on as always but
we couldn't resist noting that actor
jesse smallett finally went on trial
this week for faking a hate crime in
chicago way back in 2019 want to put a
little bow on that news story which you
probably remember well
smilet faces six felony charges for what
he did he could spend three years in
prison if he's convicted on all of them
so mullet's lawyers have argued
hilariously that he is quote the real
victim in this story but of course no
sober person on the planet believes that
jesse smallett definitely faked a hate
crime the question is how did anyone
anywhere ever fall for this story even
for a moment
looking back particularly in retrospect
it was maybe the most obvious hoax ever
perpetrated and in case you've forgotten
the details of them i'd like to savor
them tonight well here's what smollett
claimed smelly claimed that he left his
apartment in chicago alone one freezing
january night at 2 a.m to pick up a
subway sandwich
something that no one who isn't homeless
has ever done
as he walked down the street two white
men approached him and began screaming
in his face for being black and gay
because of course you're not allowed to
be either one of those things in the
city of chicago they called him the
n-word they punched him in the face they
put a chemical onto his body and then
needless to say they wrapped a noose
around his neck because you know chicago
they didn't bother to rob him their
motives were purely political this is
magic country they screamed about a city
that voted more than 83 percent for
hillary clinton
so that's the story that jesse smollette
told the police that night a new still
hanging around his neck
the police it's fair to say were
highly skeptical
the leaders of the democratic party
however were not skeptical at all in
fact the story he told was a story they
were already telling
that same year several democratic
senators including notably kamala harris
of california a personal friend of jesse
smallhands sent a letter to the justice
department the letter claimed that
attacks from white supremacist trump
voters were among this country's
greatest threats
attacks by black supremacists by
contrast were not even real in fact
harris lectured the doj saying the very
term black supremacist is a quote
fabricated term
based on a faulty assessment of a small
number of isolated incidents end quote
in other words only trump voters
commit hate crimes
and of course the media's been telling
us that ever since here's one recent
headline from cnn quote hate crime
reports in the u.s surge to the highest
level in 12 years comma fbi says
where's all this hate coming from well
according to cnn it's anti-immigrant
rhetoric
npr covered it at your expense it's
national public radio and in their
coverage they came out and blamed people
who voted for donald trump
all these white supremacists and npr
explained are mad about covid so they're
beating up asians in the streets of san
francisco and new york
just as kamala harris told us
white supremacy is the problem
so where do these numbers come from the
numbers upon which all these stories are
hung and all these political points are
made all these lies are told
well here's how the department of
justice under joe biden concluded that
we have quote more hate crimes than
we've had in 12 years
first they changed the definition of
hate crime
now a hate crime
by the way is that even a real category
of crime how is it different from a
crime but it is apparently and it now
includes something called discrimination
based on gender identity well no one can
quite agree on what that is but it's a
crime
then the fbi noticed that nearly 90 of
law enforcement agencies across the
country had been reporting no hate
crimes within their jurisdictions
because actually there's not a lot of
hate in the country because it's pretty
nice country most people are not racist
at all most people are really kind
they're americans but that's not a
conclusion we can sell to cnn or npr or
get elected on in the midterm
so
the biden justice department badgered an
additional 600 federal law enforcement
agencies and local police departments
into reporting hate crimes under this
new expanded definition of the term hate
crime
so if you're following this
hate crimes whatever those are didn't
actually rise in frequency the number of
agencies that were commanded to report
hate crimes went up quite dramatically
and then the fbi encouraged law
enforcement agencies to report any
possible hate crime
even if the crime derived from an
obviously false report
and that's why more than 80 percent of
the hate crime suspects investigated by
the feds from 2005 to 2019 were never
prosecuted why is that because they were
fake
but they still show up in statistics and
they still allow npr to tell you
that people who would disagree with
anthony fauci are beating up asians on
the street in new york
right
so it's a fiction it's yet another lie
engineered by the by the administration
and carried forth as fact by the media
they did it for political reasons
they've been doing it for years in fact
in fact they've done it for so long they
started to believe it was actually true
and that ladies and gentlemen is why
they took jesse smollett seriously when
no normal person would
the story was absurd from the very first
day but they believed it completely in
case you've forgotten here was their
response
we've got some breaking news actor and
musician jesse smallett from the hit
show empire was attacked and beaten
early this morning in chicago and police
say it could be a hate crime there are
many indications of a hate crime here
they are looking for two suspects who
are apparently wearing make america
great again hats we have a media that's
saying it's a debate whether or not what
just happened to jesse small it is a
hate crime it's absurd you know jesse
smell it had a noose on his neck
just this week and the media has really
cast so much doubt on his story which i
find so personally offensive that a gay
black man is targeted and then suddenly
he becomes the victim of people's
disbelief he said his attackers hurled
racial and homophobic slurs at him
this is america in 2019.
a lot of talking with the eyes closed a
lot of empathy a lot of empathy we
should know by the way that jesse smalls
apparel is also a in addition to being
an actor a musician what instrument we
have no idea but he's a musician too
anyway this is america in 2019
we just heard from cnn and that was true
actually but not in the way the robot on
cnn meant it by 2019 in america it was
actually getting pretty difficult for
the average black person to get beaten
up on the street for having the wrong
skin color as jesse smellet found out
personally if you wanted to have racists
throw bleach in your face and hang a
noose around your neck you had to pay
nigerian bodybuilders to do it and the
going rate at the time was 3 500 bucks
that's not cheap but then violent
anti-black racism was getting extremely
hard to find it was a rare commodity
and yet somehow abc news was not aware
of any of this at abc news it is always
1958 in mississippi
so to the geniuses at abc news this
sounded totally plausible completely
jesse smallett
could sense this and he took full
advantage of it watch this
i see
the attacker
masked
and
he said
this maggot country
punches me right in the face and there
is no doubt in your mind
what motivated this attack i could only
go off of their words
i mean
who says
empire
this maga country
ties a noose around your neck
and pours bleach on you
so downtown chicago
such a seething hotbed of support for
donald trump that progressive black
actors can no longer walk down the
street without risking being lynched
it's maggot country in downtown chicago
now who wouldn't laugh at that
well let's see robin roberts of abc
she didn't laugh it sounded absolutely
real to her so she let jesse smallette
keep rolling
why do you think you were targeted i can
just assume i mean
i come really really hard against
45.
it's the highest paid woman in
television
but as jessie smallett explained to her
i came really really hard at 45 meaning
donald trump
so if you lived here at the time in
america 2019 that makes a kind of sense
back in 2019 very few actors had the
bravery to criticize the fascist trump
regime they were too afraid
so instead they went along with it like
quizlings the oscars were like a maga
rally that year to speak out against
donald trump from hollywood was to risk
your very life white supremacist thugs
were likely to attack you with nooses on
your way back from subway
and that's why we remembered jesse
smallett for his unique courage
virtually alone in our media landscape
swollen was willing to take the risk he
publicly admitted that he votes for the
democratic party now his friends pleaded
with him to stay quiet about this and to
stay safe
that's the kind of man jesse smallett is
he wouldn't
some called him a hero for that his
friend kamala harris did harris describe
what happened to jesse smallhead as a
quote attempted modern-day lynching
nancy pelosi said it was a homophobic
attack and an affront to our humanity
eric swalwell of california told us
there were countless jessie smallettes
in this filthy racist nation of ours
quote hate crimes like this are
happening more frequently egged on by
careless hate-filled rhetoric
notice the redundancy
senator cory booker meanwhile demanded
anti-lynching legislation as if we
didn't already have that and so on
so in a landscape like this with the
most powerful people in the country
cheering him on like a modern dietrich
bonhoeffer is it really surprising that
jesse smallat just pushed it as far as
he could no it's not very surprising
what's surprising
is that absolutely nothing smallett said
no matter how transparently ridiculous
or melodramatic or embarrassing or
obviously non-factual no matter what he
said none of it aroused even the
slightest
hint of skepticism of any kind from
hardened newswoman robert roberts of abc
justice mullet could have claimed
absolutely anything trump killed my
family trump and vladimir putin burned a
cross in my yard
and robert roberts would have had the
same reaction
awe struck love
watch this
it's been two weeks since that night
left actor jessie smallette bruised but
not broken i still want to believe
with everything that has happened
that there's something called justice
because if i stop believing that
then what's it all
for thank you chelsea
beautiful thank you josie he's bruised
not broken is there anyone who writes
scripts at abc who doesn't speak
entirely in cliches
not yet
well eventually
thank god the police took over robert
roberts had to relinquish her control
over the story the cops interviewed the
people in the end who jesse smelled had
hired to beat him up the two black guys
turns out smollett had paid for the
noose
and the bleach
so you've got to ask once the evidence
arrived how did all of his supporters
react how did for example his friend
kamala harris respond to this news well
here she is
your initial tweet of him would you like
to make an amendment to your original
sentiment
which tweet what tweet that about saying
that it is a modern day lynching that
sorry
jesse smaller
okay so i will say this about that case
i think that the facts are still
unfolding and
i'm very
concerned about obviously the initial
allegation that he made about what might
have happened
so would you like to adjust your
hysteria to the facts would you like to
acknowledge reality no i don't think so
it's still about white racism it's all
about mega country in downtown chicago
so obviously there's a pretty
inconvenient story for the people who
bought it hook line and sinker not only
the dishonest but a lot of them are
really dumb that's their main secret
so after this happened kamala harris's
allies got to work making the story
going away go away michelle obama aide
reached out to a partisan d.a in chicago
called kim fox and had charges against
jesse smallett dismissed
oh that's what happens when you have
friends you're so powerless you can get
michelle obama to make it go away
but now thankfully for the sake of the
justice smollett says he wanted that
decision has been reversed
so finally this week the smallnet trial
is underway he's on trial for lying
about the attack and as part of the
trial learning some pretty interesting
new information about the extent of the
scam for example
the same day that jesse smallett cried
in his interview with robin roberts
which he described as beautiful jesse
beautiful
he was texting one of the people
he claims beat him up because
he's black and gay and here's what he
wrote brother i love you i stand with
you smallout wrote i know 100 you and
your brother did nothing wrong these are
people he paid to put a noose around his
neck small was also on videotape
conducting a dry run of the attack the
day before it happened
you're not hearing a ton about this in
the media why is that
because it undermines the core claim
that they are making which is people who
vote for candidates they don't like are
dangerous people of a certain color are
dangerous the violence in america is
committed by their political enemies
when in fact that's a lie
and we know it's alive because there are
real numbers out there and you're
welcome to look them up if you like and
they do not tell you that trump voters
are the ones behind the crime wave
currently in progress
so once you learn that one thing is a
lie you might start to ask yourself hmm
what else are they lying about and
that's not a process they welcome hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else